this is distributed sweet prologue
development i'm ann ogborn
uh feel free to ask questions at any
time
i'm hoping this becomes kind of a
discussion
there's been some interesting things
going on in the sweet prologue world in
the
last nine months particularly this
summer
uh started with torborne lager at the
university of gottenberg
wrote a library called pensions and
that that does some distributed
programming we're going to look at it in
detail here
and he and jan ever since have been
working very hard at building up this
little
distributed ecosystem around it
and uh and uh things are just kind of
catching fire and it's
kind of an interesting time some of the
stuff i'm talking about is
brand new uh i
was going to show a robot in this time
slot
and i didn't have access to the robot
so uh you are instead getting
the rare chance to have like something
that's much shorter than the usual
turnaround time for docs
so as a result you get to hear about new
stuff
so i'm going to show you the
uh i'm going to show you the library
i'll start out by motivating
it a little show you the architecture
show you the api
and then at the end i'll kind of talk
about some of the consequences
so what's people's knowledge here about
prologue from
like i've never heard of prologue to
like i am a commercial developer
cool so
i'll try and fill in for for folks who
aren't prologue programmers
um i can't turn this into a like
prologue 101 but
but i will try and uh cope with that oh
and and
how how much do people know about
semantic web
and rdf and like
great great okay so
um uh
i'm sorry i'm going the wrong way
all right um so i'm going to start out
by
kind of motivating pensions and then
i'll explain and explain the larger
pieces
and some of their roles this is how
people interact with servers today
if you want a bunch of data what you've
got to do is you've got to go to every
feed that you want data off of
read their specs and individually like
kind of grind through their api
right so there's this proprietary api
for each one this is
not convenient um
furthermore you have
a um
if you need to do any kind of federated
query
you're in trouble because you can't
really do any kind of
query that requires back and forth
reasoning
across these machines very easily
right so you're going you've got a fair
amount of code they had of you
um and we're kind of asking does it need
to be this way
furthermore we do this to ourselves
most of us spend our lives working on
web applications
where there's a front end it's got ajax
calls and there are back ends
and there's one eary end point for every
ajax call how many people work on a
system like that
yeah so
how can we get out of that well first of
all
kind of what causes this large number of
of
of orient points um
one is simply that the if we look at
this as a language problem
the base language if you have a server
and i'm querying it the base language
is give me
this thing you know give me
this end point with these parameters
with the search string and you hand me
something back
that's not very combinatorial we're used
to languages
where we can combine things so instead
we end up with a combinatorial explosion
of
of ajax apis how many people here work
on a system
that has a lot of very similar ajax apis
so okay so
uh how can we solve a problem well
if we only had one user let's say we've
got one user who
wants to federate this data
and and we personally know the user
there's a solution we'd give them shell
access
on our server right now they
sort of by definition can't be doing
anything in any more complicated the way
than the server itself because they've
got access to all the same
data and same coding tools as the server
right so they can start up a prologue
interactor and
go to town
this is not great security right
furthermore if you are
trying to serve anonymous data you know
data anonymously
to millions of people if you're doing
the twitter feed this is not going to
work
this is not a solution right but it's a
direction for a solution
so what torborne said was well
what if we could give you out a
sandboxed
limited
prologue interactor
so that's what he did he said okay we'll
we'll have three assists
we're gonna have three major roles
hang on i'm gonna come down here um
application the application offers to
make
what are called pensions these
sandboxed vms the master the foreign
server
then requests a pension
gets back an id and then it can use that
id
to make non-deterministic queries just
like if you're setting up the interactor
okay and as long as the application is
safe
we're safe right it can it can moderate
it can manage the code
so
this is a sample pension universe we've
got
um we've got a guy he's got a server
and he's made pensions on on
a couple of other servers and each of
those has a couple of applications that
it exposes
some sort of api through
and he's made several of them
you can also do it from a web page you
don't actually have to go back to the
server right
and we have a javascript live
this also greatly simplifies that web
page and that server might be the same
company
that server might have served that web
page
because now we've got a
and we've got a much nicer way of
doing queries back for ourselves
because we don't have to go through
a step that goes through this very
limited language of http
we can just do non-deterministic queries
to get rows for example
also we can do things like store
temporary state and so on
and and get around a lot of the
messiness of
of dealing with the fact that we're in a
client server system
with this uh and we're finding in
practices just
incredibly fast developed this way
now you might want to make a pension
for your own on your own on an
application
running inside your own vm that is this
lower server might want to make
a pendulum within that application
that's useful because now you've got
a separate vm and you can do a lot of
things that are clean
like just doing a retract all you don't
have to worry for example about
kind of which user i am right i can make
one for each user
in the system and i can have sort of
large scale objects okay people clear
about the architecture
so all right now i want to look in more
detail about
what exactly the vm gets
this slave pendant this is the server's
total prologue knowledge base
we obviously can't serve this this has
got shell in it
and halt and
and so this is obviously not secure
the default pending application
is called sandbox and it's sort of odd
like you know the equivalent of object
it's the root of
most pension applications
so the sandbox will only execute code
that it believes is
safe and what it calls
safe uh you know is
there's a long list of you know member
is safe
open is not safe right
so
so it will do code analysis before it
runs the code
now when you start the application
you can import
added knowledge into the
into the application which means you're
right this is probably your apis
right this is things it can call
however of course
this is potentially unsafe right
like our junior programmer like
managed to to like put shell
in the middle of something and
there's an easy and obvious escape
around it
um so
it does a code analysis again we're in
prolog we can do code analysis
and munch is a piece out
and it actually just will like not do
things that are unsafe
um
however of course there are things you
always want to do that
are in theory unsafe for example
if you want to allow users to store
files
on your system you know if they're going
to persist
data on your system they're going to
have to do interact with the database or
the file system or something at some
point
so you can mark things and just
in the code and just say that's safe
there's one there's one more piece that
is passed or that is added to this
and that is when you create a pension
you can pass some additional code
and say please add this to the pension
that code is often used for things like
your session data or personalization
data
or options but it can also be used
but that section can also be used for
things like
i want to do a series of queries and
keep state between them
or i want to
do a bunch of queries and they all
depend on like
some kind of ugly long piece of code and
i don't want to pass it with every
query so i'll just like define
some bit of code i need
now one other thing i pointed out about
this
this is unique to this pension right to
this slave
which is so it's not shared
and of course we can't allow people to
pass us halt
either so
we're going to remove halt those aren't
like less prologue knowledge halt uh
terminates the it's how you quit the
prologue
the top level so it's clearly not
something you want out of people outside
calling um
uh so we're going to remove anything we
consider unsafe
and there's really no override for that
for obvious reasons
now whoop okay so this is going to be
your net knowledge base
now i said sometimes you might want to
make
a pension within your own server one
reason here is we could craft what this
knowledge base is
so imagine that i'm doing like
remember detective games that were
popular in the mid 90s
where there were a bunch of characters
wandering around and
you had to find the right character and
ask them the right questions at the
right times
if you're going to implement one of
those this would be the way you do it is
each one would have its own knowledge
base and it can do its own set of
inference so you can
very flexibly alter
the behavior of the system by
kind of the left hand bump
by altering by you know it gives you a
way to override behavior
okay now
so let's look at the query
structure any questions so far
no feel free to ask questions here
so okay i'm going to show you some
client code
this is from another prolog server how
you
would call this thing it doesn't have to
be in prologue at the moment we
we have prologue and javascript
clients written when things settle down
we'll probably write them in a bunch of
other languages
so here a source text
source text is an option that
lets us pass a little bit of code that's
that's our left-hand bump and in this
case all we're doing is using the
uh server as a compute engine because
i'm just going to pass it
all the code i want to execute
and uh the the url
of the of the server and really all you
have to do to start up a pension server
is use module on sam on the sandbox
and on pensions and
start a http server and it's there
and then we call event loop and give it
a handler
and it will it will pass back
and then the handler when we get
messages
we'll get a create messages and then we
respond
with a um with a query
and then we'll do it it'll give us
success and it'll give us true and more
this is the blink equivalent of the
blinking cursor
so we'll call next and we'll keep
getting them and eventually we'll get
one with false
and then and then we can do whatever we
want in this case we happen to be
destroying the pendulum we're done with
it
but we don't have to be uh we could
go ahead and and use this and so the
pension could be stateful
okay this is essentially the same thing
in javascript
uh a bunch of
uh in this case i've i've at my
additional code is just in a script
block of type x prolog so you see that
on the left and then
sorry i have you have to kind of
rearrange code to get it on slides
um and then on the right
a little bit of javascript that makes up
engine and calls it
nothing very fancy this is a pretty
simple api
which is
okay sorry okay
i want to at this point give a demo of
all this
so um
this is swish this is a shell we've uh
we've got that just basically wrap some
uh some ui around the javascript code
that i
showed you on the left hand this left
hand panel
your left hand panel uh
we've got uh is a space to put code
uh there's a query space for a query
and then above it is where the output
will be
um and hang on i got to get back over
here
so i'm going to just load an example
program i'm going to show you the 8
queens
this is like standard prologue example
now when i click first it'll go ahead
and do a create
on the server which is on a local host i
knew better than to
depend on the internet at the conference
and then
uh and then it'll go ahead and do an
ask with what whatever was here
and now i can just do next and of course
there's many solutions to this right
so this is the equivalent of the stop
or of the period this is the semicolon
so we're done
that's that's my little demo
we're learning that uh
we're learning that using pensions can
make make
things simpler um there's another way
to interact with the client
rpc pension underscore rpc
is a non-deterministic call that just
takes an earl
and the second argument and does call
on the second argument so if you execute
this
pension rpc is itself non-deterministic
it's going to return op
and then newt and then mees
i oh i'm i'm not going to really cover
the i o because i know it's changing
this week
um i will say uh
if you if you start doing output from a
pension
and and you go home from all excited
from this talk and immediately start
coding
like there's
currently a little bit of trick but but
the change this week will
will remove the the trick
the problem is that of course this is
over ajax and the client has to start
the
the problem and it doesn't know how much
output the
the server has so
uh okay
let's hear whoop all right
questions about all that no
um you'll remember we imported code into
the sandbox right
on the right hand bump now um
i want to show you how to do that it's
really deadly simple as well
there's just the business that we don't
usually use module
which is prologues import into uh
into other modules than the one we're in
but this is the syntax for it
so it's use module pending sandbox
and the name of your
uh and the name of your
you know module with your apis and then
anything that's public
in that module becomes public
so here i've got
some random code that that i can
import in and then use so the pension
now can call this
now remember that i said that you're
going to have to mark anything that's
unsafe as explicitly safe or it'll
remove it right
so the way you do this
is you use a multifile how many people
know multifiles
um oh okay um
multi-files uh decl declaration that
says
uh the code for this predicate is spread
throughout multiple files
so do not remove ones from other font
that all
you already have in your in your
knowledge base when you compile this
this uh file
so a sandbox safe primitive
it says is multifile it's actually
declared in
in sandbox of course
but you can add a clause to it the fact
that you're adding a clause
means in this case i've just got a fact
right so as long as i have anything that
looks like my apis colon
my unsafe a module qualified
call to my unsafe we're fine
but i could be calling
but this isn't an arbitrary prologue
predicate
so i could make certain for example that
i only call my unsafe with a value less
than three
just by making this a rule which is nice
now you can
you can make more complex definitions of
what constitutes safety
okay so what does all this give us
well imagine you're in an rpc and
a semantic web world and
you want to do a federated query that is
i've got several servers that are
serving rdf
if they're sparkle end points
you're gonna have to go through all the
sparkle
impedance bump and if they're just raw
prologue endpoints
you're going to have to go through the
fact that
again you're you're trying to federate a
query over multiple servers
which ordinarily would mean like sucking
down
each table and then doing it locally but
here
we can actually just write our query
using pension rpc and this query
is essentially the same thing as a
sparkle when clause
right so this is a very cool thing about
uh about using prologue
with semantic web stuff is that these
this very fundamental resolution
mechanism
for rdf is actually the same
sld resolution mechanism
that we know and love from prologue it's
the
same as the the prologue execution model
so
so this really kind of simplifies your
life
um if you'd like to know more about this
aspect of it
the cleopatra the cleopatra is a sparkle
server for
suite prologue written in sweep our log
and this white paper is really useful
for understanding that relationship
so where are we going well around this
we've written a couple of other things
just to kind of get more collaborative
tools because we realize we kind of have
a core of something
so jan added websocket support
late this summer
and atop that we have a tool
uh we have a little library called
hub.pl
which does broadcasting across multiple
brow
basically usually out to a bunch of web
pages
so uh this
upper upper left is
a diagram editor that i've been working
on
that really is very short
um that uh
that is completely collaborative
uh you move you move one of those boxes
and it'll move on all the
everybody's page throughout the system
we have a chat application we have
the shell and we're now building out
some app
some more major applications atop this
this little test tester shell
um torborne is building
a teaching tool for teaching prologue
online
jan has been jen did some work just
last week or so basically refactoring it
so that it was
fairly modular so you could kind of
build custom
editors with it and
and uh greatly improving the editor on
the left hand side
and then jan is going to build a data
browser
with this thing that will allow you to
browse basically anything that's in your
cert
on your server side that is exposed
so you could have a pension that exposed
almost everything
that was protected by kind of a
developer password
um and then
in the longer term we're hoping
to turn this into something that's
industrial strength enough
that it can replace the old xpc
uh based editor but we're real committed
to
that not happening until until
everybody's happy that that's happening
so that's kind of where we're headed um
resources this is new stuff so so it's
still got
sharp edges um you can get this
and and i don't expect anybody to like
get all the urls and the
30 seconds the slides up but
my slides are going to be on annie poo
on github
and you may need the to get
the sources or the nightlys to get the
latest stuff
so actually you're probably good if
you're above
seven 122 on sweet prologue
there are currently two versions of of
this
shell up online if you want to play with
them
one at pensions.suiteprolog and the
other swish
my my little diagram editors at
whiteboard on my
on the chat thing is on jan's
private github and i'll warn you
the javascript documentation is only
available through this
link which at the moment has no like
like there is no link in the universe
that goes to it
so uh hey you're seeing bleeding edge
stuff
and all of this may change by next week
uh i want to thank torborne and john for
answering lots of questions while i was
prepping this
and of course for writing all this cool
stuff and uh i want to thank you for
listening to me blather any questions
i just i got one two
yeah but the pension in turn is
communicating with
um an instance of hub behind the scene
yeah yeah
um you mean like submitting sleep for a
long time
there's a call with time out in the in
the swivel lives
and that that's the call that's i think
used so there's a ti eventually it'll
time out if you just write a
you know a [ __ ] invert invert my
five thousand by five thousand matrix
yeah you could you could do retract
um it has a oh you mean you mean retract
on the
on the larger pendant that's a good
question
or you mean retract outside of or
if i do a retract of a system predicate
what would happen um actually sweet
prologue won't let you retract system
predicates
and i assume there's a call to
to like remove something from system
like unbless it and that call is
undoubtedly marked unsafe
but but the system prolog the system
stuff
is marked safe you may it could be a
a hole i will try it i i managed to
knock the
the two test stations down the other
night i
i i would hereby place my historical
claim
i wrote the first penjan virus in the
world
so um let's see did i answer your
question
yeah okay
30k it's it's a thread uh the heaviest
part of it is that it starts a prologue
thread
which of course will be red or green
depending on the details of
and i had there was a question out here
no okay
about the oh thank you oh and this
evening there is a birds of a feather
for logic programmers so tell your logic
programmer friends
we're going to be getting together i
guess that's at the ballroom
yeah it's back at union station and kind
of down
in the ballrooms um so
uh and that'll start at seven
so thanks woohoo
you